can you explain what you mean when you
say that the negative externalities are
coupled to an economy that depends on
exponential growth
so
it's if you if you think about it just
in the first principle way the idea is
supposed to be something like
there are real goods and services that
people want that improve their life that
we care about
and so
the services might not be physical Goods
directly there may be things humans are
doing but they still depend upon lots of
goods right if you are going to provide
a consultation over a zoom meeting you
have to have
laptops and satellites and uh
power lines and Mining and all those
things so you can't separate the service
industry from the goods industry so
there's physical stuff that we want
and to mediate the access to that
and the exchange of it we think about it
through a currency so it's supposed to
be there's this physical stuff and the
currency is a way of being able to
mediate the incentives and exchange of
it
but the currency starts to gain its own
physics right so we make a currency that
has no intrinsic value it is just
representative of any kind of value we
could want
but the moment we do something like
interest
where we're now exponentiating the
monetary Supply independent of an actual
automatic growth of goods or services to
not debase the value of the currency
you have to also exponentiate the total
amount of goods and services
and everybody's seen how compounding
interest works right because you have a
particular amount of interest and then
you have interest on that amount of
Interest so you do get an exponential
curve
obviously that's just the beginning
Financial Services as a whole and all of
the Dynamics where you have money making
on money
I mean that you expand the monetary
Supply
on an exponential curve which was based
on the idea that there is a nap a
natural exponential curve of population
anyways and there's a natural growth of
goods and services correlated but that
was true at an early part of a curve
that was supposed to be an S curve right
you have an inexponential curve that
inflex goes into an X's curve but we
don't have the s-curve part of the
financial system planned the financial
system has to keep doing exponential
growth or it breaks and not only is that
key to the financial system because what
does it mean they have a financial
system without interest say it's a very
deeply different system
that formalizing that was also key to
our solution to not have World War III
right the the
history of the world in terms of War
does not look great that the major
Empires and major Nations don't stay out
of violent conflict with each other very
long
and uh World War one was supposed to be
the war that ended all wars but it
wasn't we had World War II now this one
really has to be the war that ends all
major superpower Wars because of the
bomb we can't do that again
and the primary basis of war is one of
the primary bases had been resources
which was a particular Empire wanted to
grow and get more stuff and that meant
taking it from somebody else
and so the idea of if we could
exponentially grow Global GDP everybody
could have more without taking each
other's stuff it's so highly positive
song that we don't have to go zero
someone more
so the whole post-world War II banking
system the bread and woods monetary
system Etc was part of the how do we not
have World War along with Michel shared
destruction the UN and other
International intergovernmental
organizations
but that let's EX Let's uh exponentially
grow the monetary system also meant that
if you have a whole bunch more dollars
and you don't have more goods and
services the dollars become worth less
and it's just inflation and debasing the
currency
so now you have an artificial incentive
to keep growing the
um physical economy which also means
that the materials economy has to have
an exponential amount of nature getting
turned from nature into stuff into trash
and pollution in a linear materials
economy and you don't get to
exponentially do that on finite
biosphere forever
so the economy is tied to interest and
that's at the root of this of what you
just explained not at the root of every
catastrophe
interest is the beginning of what all of
the financial services do but there is a
there's an embedded growth obligation of
which interest is the first thing you
can see on the economic system the
embedded growth obligation that creates
exponentiation of it tied to the
physical world where exponential
currents don't get to run forever is one
of the problems
there are a handful this is when we're
thinking meta crisis what are the
underlying issues this is one of the
underlying issues there's quite a few
other ones that we can look at to say if
we really want to address the issues we
have to address it at this level
what's the issue with transitioning from
something that's exponential to sub
exponential when it comes to the economy
what's the issue with it
um well I mean
there's a bunch of ways we could go
there is an old refrain from the hippie
days and it seems very obvious I think
as soon as anyone thinks about it which
is that you can't run an exponential
growth system on a finite Planet forever
that seems kind of obvious and intuitive
because it's so obvious and intuitive
there's a lot of counters to it right
one counter is oh we're not going to run
it on the finite Planet forever we're
going to become an interplanetary
species mine asteroids ship our ways to
the sun blah blah blah
um
I don't think that we are anywhere near
close independent of the ethical or
aesthetic argument on if us obliterating
our planet's carrying capacity and then
exporting that to the rest of the
universe is a good good or lovely idea
or not independent of that argument
I the timelines by which that could
actually meet the humanity super
organism growing needs relative to the
timelines where this thing starts
failing don't work
um so that's not an answer
that said that the attempt to even try
to get there quicker is a utilization of
resources here that is speeding up the
breakdown here faster than it is
providing alternatives
the other answer people have to why
there could be a exponential growth
forever is because uh digital
right that more and more money
is a result of software being created uh
results of inner
Digital entertainment being created and
that there's a lot less physical impact
of that and so
we can keep growing digital Goods
because it doesn't affect the physical
plan and physical supply chain so we can
keep the exponential growth up forever
that's very much the kind of Silicon
Valley take on it
uh of course that has an effect
it does not solve the problem
and it's pretty straightforward to see
why
which is
for
um
let's go ahead and say software in
particular
does software have to run on Hardware
where the computer systems and server
Banks and satellites and Etc require
massive mining which also requires a
Financial system in police and courts to
maintain the entire cybernetic system
that runs all that yes it does
um
does a lot more compute require more of
that more atoms adjacent Services energy
yes
but also
um
for us to consider software valuable
it's either because we're engaging with
what's we're engaging with what it's
doing directly so that's the case in
entertainment or education or something
but then it is interfacing with the
finite resource called human attention
of which there is a finite amount
or because we're not necessarily being
entertained or educated or engaging with
it but it's doing something for us to
again to consider valuable it is doing
something to the physical world so the
software is engaging say supply chain
optimization or new
uh modeling for how to make better
transistors or something like that
but it then it's still moving atoms
around using energy and physical space
which is a finite resource if it is not
either affecting the physical world or
affecting our attention why would we
value it we don't
so it still bottoms out on
finite resources so I can't just keep
producing an infinite amount of software
where you get more and more content that
nobody has time to watch and more and
more designs for physical things that we
don't have physical atoms for energy for
you get a diminishing return on the
value of it if it's not coupled to
things that are that are finite right
the value of it is in modulating things
that are also finite so there's a
coupling coefficient there
you still don't get an exponential curve
so what we just did is say the Old
Hippie refrain you can't run an
exponential economy on a finite Planet
forever the alt the counters to it don't
hold
what about mind uploading or some
computer brain interface to allow us to
have more attention exponentially
um
yeah so uh it's another it's kind of
that's almost like the hybrid of the
other two right which is get Beyond this
planet
um and do it more digitally so it could
be on this brain
um and uh become digital gods and uh
Singularity Universe
um
I
again I think they're pretty interesting
arguments we can have ethically
aesthetically and epistemically about
why that is neither
possible
nor desirable
um but independent of those
I don't think it's anywhere close
and same like the multi-planetary
species it is nowhere near close enough
to address any of the timelines we have
by which economy has to change because
the growth imperative on the economy as
is is moving us towards catastrophic
tipping points so if it were close would
that change your assessment or you still
have other issues
if it were close
then we would have to say
um
first that is implying
that we have a good reason to think that
it's possible
right that it's possible to
and that means all the axioms that
Consciousness is substrate independent
that the Consciousness is purely a
function of compute strong
computationalism holds that we could map
the states of the brain and or if we
believe in embodied cognition the
physiology adequately to represent that
informational system on some other
substrate
that that could operate with an amount
of energy that is
um and substrate that's possible blah
blah blah so first we have to believe
that's possible I I would question
literally every one of the axioms or
assumptions I just said we're going to
get to that
we would say
is it desirable and how do we know how
ahead of time
and now you get something very much like
how do I know that the AI is sentient
which the
for the most part on all AI risk topics
whether it's sentient or not is
irrelevant whether it does stuff it's
all that matters
but the how do you tell if it's sentient
and all of the
um Chalmers P zombie questions or
whatever are actually really hard
because what we're asking is how can we
use third person observation to infer
something about the nature of first
person given the ontological difference
between them
so how would we know that that future is
desirable what would the are there safe
to fail tests and what would we have to
test to know it to start making that
conversion
um but
I don't
I don't think we have to answer any of
those questions because I don't think
that anybody that is working on whole
brain emulation things that we are close
enough that it would address the
timeline of the
um economy issues that you're addressing
let's attempt to address one of the
questions about substrate Independence
what are your views is consciousness
something that our biological brains do
or that it requires a development from
an embryonic stage like whatever it is
that produced us there's something
special about us or animals or is it
something that can be transferred or
started up booted up from scratch into
what's not us like decidedly not us a
computer
okay
so
this is now much more a proper Theory of
Everything conversation than the topic
that we intended for the day which is um
about AI risk so what I will do is say
briefly the conclusion of my thoughts on
this without actually going into it in
depth but I would be happy to explore
that at some point
um
I think
that how I come to my position on it
to try to do a kind of proper
construction takes a while so briefly
I'll say
I'm not a strong computationalist
meaning don't believe it mind
universe sentience qualia is purely a
function of computation
I am not an emergent physicalist
that believes that Consciousness is an
epiphenomena of
non-conscious physics that in the same
way that we have
weak emergence more of a particular
property through certain kind of
combinatorics or strong emergence new
properties emerging out of
some type of interaction where that
hadn't occurred before like a cell
respirating well none of the molecules
that make it up respirate
I believe in Weak emergence that happens
all the time you get more of certain
qualities happens in Metallurgy when you
combine Metals where the combined
tensile strength or
sharing strength or whatever is more
than you would expect as a result of the
nature of how the molecular lattices
form you get more of a thing of the same
type I believe in strong emergence which
is you get new types of things you
didn't have before like respiration and
replication out of Parts none of which
do that
but those are all still in the domain of
third person accessible things
the idea of radical emergence that you
get the emergence of first person out of
third person or third person out of
first person which is idealism on one
side and physicalism on the other
I don't buy either of I think that
idealism and physical ISM are similar
types of reductionism
where they both take certain ontological
assumptions to bootload their
epistemology and then get self
referential Dynamics
so I don't think that if a computational
system gets Advanced enough
automatically Consciousness pops out of
it that's one
two I do think that the process of a
system self-organizing
is
fundamentally connected to the nature of
experience of selfness and things that
are being designed and are not
self-organizing where the
um
boundary between the system and its
environment that exchanges energy and
information and matter across the
boundary is a
uh autopoetic process
I do believe that's fundamental to the
nature of things that have self-other
recognition
and
on substrate Independence I do believe
that carbon and silicon are different in
pretty fundamental ways that don't
Orient to the same types of
um
possibilities
and
I think that
that's actually pretty important to the
AI risk argument
um but so I'll just go ahead I'll just
go ahead and say those things I also
don't think
I believe that embodied cognition in the
demacio sense is important and that a
scan of purely brain States is
insufficient
I also don't think that a scan of brain
States is possible even in theory
and sorry to interrupt I know you said
it you don't believe it's possible what
if it is and you're able to scan your
brain State and body state so we take
into account the embody cognition
sure
so
I think that
okay it's not simply a matter of
scanning the brain State we need to scan
the rest of the central nervous system
now we also have to get the peripheral
nervous system now we have to get the
endocrine system no all of the cells
have the production of and reception of
um
neuroendocrine type things we have to
scan the whole thing
does that then extend to the microbiome
firearm
Etc
I would argue yes does it then extend to
the environment I would argue yes where
uh where does
where does that stop its extension is
actually a very important question so I
would take the embodied cognition a step
further
um
the other thing is Stuart Kaufman's
arguments about
Quantum amplification to the mesoscopic
level
that
quantum mechanical events don't just
fully cancel themselves out at the
subatomic level and at the level of
brains everything that is happening is
um
straightforwardly classical but that
there is
quantum mechanical AE
some fundamental kind of indeterminism
built in phenomena they end up affecting
what happens at the level of molecules
now then one can say well is that just
mean we have to add a certain amount of
a random function in or is there
something else
this is a big rabbit hole I would say
for another time because then you get
into
quantum entanglement and coherence so
you get something that is neither
uh perfectly random meaning without
pattern you get important distribution
even on the single one but it's also not
deterministic or with hidden variables
so do I think that what's happening in
the brain body system
is not purely deterministic
and also as a result of that means you
could not measure or scan it even in
principle in a kind of Heisenberg sense
yes I think that
have you heard of David walpart and his
limits on inference systems inference
machines sorry
I have not studied his work okay well
anyway he Echoes something similar which
says that you can't have laplace's demon
even in a classical world you can't have
laplacious demon so let me talk about
the economy which only on your podcast
would happen
yeah
why is it that if somehow this
exponential curve starts to get to where
the S is the top of the s that the
halting or the slowing down of the
economy is something that's so
catastrophic and calamitous rather than
something that would mutate and if we
need to just at that point as it starts
to slow down we make minor changes here
and there is this something that's
entirely new like will it all come
Crashing Down
um okay so well let me make the question
clear it sounds like look the economy is
tied to exponential growth we can't grow
exponentially virtually no one believes
that so at some point and let's just
imagine it's three decades just to give
some numbers so at some point three
decades from now this exponential curve
for all of the economy will start to
show its legs and start to weaken and
we'll see that it's nearing the S part
so what does that mean that there's then
fire in the streets that the buildings
don't work that the water doesn't run
anymore like what will happen
okay
so people
uh often make jokes about
physicists in particular starting to
look at biology and language and society
and modeling in particularly funny
reductionist ways because they try to
map the entire economy through the
second law of Thermodynamics or
something like that
and
because what we're really talking about
is the maximally complex and anthro
complex thing in embedded complexity we
can because we're talking about all of
human motives
and how do humans respond to the idea
that uh
there is fundamentally limits on the
growth possible to them
or there's less stuff possible for them
or that they're whether it's issues that
are associated with
um environmental extraction so here's
one of the classic challenges is that
the problems the catastrophic risks many
of them in the environmental category
are the result of cumulative action long
term where the upsides of the result of
individual action short term and the
asymmetry between those is particularly
problematic it's why you get this
Collective Choice making challenge
meaning if I cut down a tree for
September
I don't obviously perceive the change to
the atmosphere or to the climate or to
watersheds or to anything but my bank
account goes up through being able to
sell that Lumber immediately
and the same is true if I fish or if I
do anything like that but when you run
the content categorical imperative
across it and you have the movement from
half a billion people doing it to a
pre-industrial revolution to 8 billion
and you have something like in the
industrial World 100x resource per
capita consumption
uh just calorically measured today than
at the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution
then you start realizing okay well the
cumulative effects of that don't work
they break the they break the planet and
they start creating
um tipping points that auto propagate in
the wrong direction
but that but no individual person or
even local area doing the thing
recognizes their action as driving that
downside and how do you get Global
enforcement of the thing and if you
don't get Global enforcement why should
anyone let themselves be curtailed when
other people aren't being curtailed and
that'll give them game theoretic
advantage
so this is actually there's a handful of
asymmetries that are important to
understand with regard to risk you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy